thank you for um for saving tomorrow
Wow I just said how long have you two
been together I figured they'd say you
know what man he met her at the rally in
Colorado can you believe do you believe
it man did he get lucky
yeah he's not just the president
he's a matchmaker
[Applause]
so was that a debate or what here's my
favorite moment
there's Bloomberg's under there
somewhere so let's recap alright first
there's mini mic mini mic no boxes we
call them no boxes mini mic minimum no
boxes we call them no boxes and I hear
he's getting pounded tonight you know
he's in a debate I founded you he's
right mr. Magoo got pounded like a
dandelion in a hailstorm take a look a
billionaire who calls women phat broads
and horse-faced lesbians and no I'm not
talking about Donald Trump I'm talking
about Mayor Bloomberg he had
stop-and-frisk throwing up close to five
million young black men up against the
wall we are sick and tired of
billionaires like mr. Bloomberg seeing
huge expansions of their wealth while a
half a million people sleep out on the
street tonight we have a very few
non-disclosure agreements how many how
many is then he should have just said
only Rosie O'Donnell instead he looked
like Thurston Howell the third at an
ante for Ally he got passed around like
a porno in a frat house
you know how bad he did the hindenburg
call to offer condolences bottom line
you know Bloomberg made a fool out of
himself that night Bloomberg made a fool
out of himself less each other he's
another one who's going AHA oh I can't
breathe I can't breathe
don't ask me the question yeah and you
gotta hand it to Pocahontas she she took
Bloomberg out like a schoolmarm version
of John wick and became Bernie's
henchman a sadistic Robin to the
Bolshevik Batman maybe she is part
Native American because that felt like
Little Bighorn
then there's Joe aka Jan Brady instantly
becomes forgotten when other people are
in the room it really is the candy at
Halloween that no one eats you know the
Necco wafers the circus peanuts the
black good and plenties am i aging
myself it might be too hard on you Joe
and now Joe Biden on comebacks
look man history is filled with great
comebacks Alexander Hamilton yeah the
rough time in that duel but he lived to
tell about it
that's right Jack Dawson he went down
with the Titanic but look what happened
to him lived a long life became king of
France
yeah Old Yeller he fought that wolf got
rabies now he's the face of meow mix
tell you what else is coming back the
mullet
good do business up front party in my
pants anyway Joe was lucky by being
forgotten standing on the stage like
Bruce Willis in the sixth sense he was
already dead he just didn't know it
so why kick him let's ask him and now
Joe Biden on Michael Bloomberg look you
can't buy an election I know I've tried
I've been to all the sites QVC Etsy Hot
Topic no elections on sale there
I even tried that Amazon yeah got lost
in the rainforest cafe breed beef llama
nachos though you gotta wonder how they
get that cow to the top of the volcano
Tex Joe - Joe versus the volcano dot org
dot edu dot come on man
then there was a me versus mayor Pete
the gunfight at the glee club I wish
everyone is with as perfect as you P you
have not been in the arena doing that
work you've memorized a bunch of talking
points and a bunch of things oh wow
does Betty hey Jughead or what I can't
blame and Pete is that annoying guy at
trivia night who keeps telling everyone
his IQ and yet he always still loses
then Bernie what a sad lesson when a
capitalist and socialist are on the same
stage and it's the capitalists who gets
thrown under it and the Socialists
skates one step closer to the nomination
where he can spread is bitter hatred for
achievement all around it isn't that
what socialism really is it's not about
spreading wealth but spreading misery
driven by envy which Bernie has a
limitless supply but warning birdie won
the debate because everyone went for the
billionaire Sanders is like the
scrawniest piece of chicken in the
bucket everyone gets eaten before him
and then that grizzly chunk of poultry
ends up with a Democratic nomination I
don't know about you but I think it's
foul don't clap don't clap for that
that's terrible
so the debate became a lifeboat that
seats only five but six wanted in and
before he decided to throw that six
person out you need mob energy to
overcome common sense Bloomberg was the
only successful businessman there he's
employed thousands by making billions so
to destroy him
they used his identity to obliterate his
achievements no longer a success story
is now just an old white sexist male so
skin him alive boys but what a contrast
imagine if Trump was up there instead of
mini Mike you know how different it
would have played out sometimes you can
perceive genius by its absence and what
was missing is what Trump possesses and
I think the Dems know that by now
finally there was this what the hell was
that why is it that left-wing protesters
always sound like poltergeists it's like
it's like some screeching ghoul you
conjure up in a seance with a Ouija
board now debate should be fractious
because Trump isn't going to be kind to
whoever's left to prep for Trump you
need to be beaten by inmates with a sock
full of ball bearings because he's the
orange Godzilla and right now the Dems
are villagers running for cover
no wonder the media reacted this way
Bloomberg was awful the truth is Bernie
Sanders is on a trajectory to be the
Democratic nominee they agreed that
Bernie's the leader and Bernie will be
the leader is nothing if not something
doesn't stop listen this was a disaster
I thought it was a great night for
Donald Trump I thought it was a terrible
night for the Democrats Bernie is
allowed to win it I think they're gonna
find there in more trouble than they
thought they were in it was a big night
for Sanders I just don't see him having
any shot in a general election I'm
panicked I am absolutely mad I am so
happy that he's panicked
I for one I can't wait for the next
week's debate it's on Tuesday here's a
preview
[Applause]